[Music]  I just want to take this moment to honor  the people that were lost or that were  that we're taking we love you so much  the families we love you so much Justin  Bieber moved to tears during ariana  grande's one love Manchester benefit  concert on Sunday I'm not gonna let go  hope  [Applause]  [Music]  they're done  [Music]  put your hand up if you're not gonna let  go proceeds from the concert will go to  the victims and families affected by the  bombing at Ariana's concert on May 22nd  before I go any further I'm gonna think  I'll from the bottom of my heart from  being here today I love you so so much  earlier during the show ariana performed  for the first time since the attack that  left 22 dead and more than 100 injured  [Music]